well joining me now is Carrie Lee she
was a republican nominee for Arizona
governor one of the leading lights in
the making America great again movement
and being touted by some pundits as
president Trump's running mate in 2024
well Caroline welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored
it's so wonderful to be with you today
Pierce so we've never spoken but I've
watched you with Fascination from afar
not least because for a long time you
were doing what I'm doing you were
anchoring the news and you did that for
many years so my first question is what
on Earth possessed you to want to give
up a lovely job like this to get into
the there what can often be a hell hole
of political life
you mean why would I leave the news to
to jump into the swamp
um that is a good question and and I did
love my career for 30 years I was a
broadcast journalist and I love
um digging into issues learning about
them telling people stories but during
covid I really had an epiphany a wake-up
call that what was being pushed by the
news the mainstream corporate news was
half truths and fear tactics and really
was just dividing our country and I
could no longer lend my my heart and my
soul and my voice and my reputation to
putting out half truths I wasn't
interested in that so I did a lot of
soul searching and praying and and I
walked away from my career my very
successful career in 22 years as number
one news anchor in Arizona I walked away
from a massive paycheck and I just said
God I'm putting my life in your hands
take me where you want me and the
amazing people of Arizona reached out
they were so moved by what I I did that
they reached out to me and said would
you please run for office we need
somebody who understands us understands
our state our issues and will absolutely
represent us and so I reluctantly went
into politics I didn't even know how to
run for office I had to call the Arizona
Republican party and say how do you run
for office I mean I'm I'm really at the
heart of it just a mom who is concerned
about where our state is going and so
that's how I ended up running for office
little did I know that we would lead an
amazing movement here in the state
bringing in Independence Democrats and
Republicans to bring about change here
in Arizona and and secure our streets
and secure our border unfortunately the
election didn't go the way uh that we
wanted to because we have a lot of fraud
in our elections and and we're working
through that right now okay
well that was a good pitch but let me
just put a butt in the into the works
there because I'm curious about a lot of
of course a lot of things have happened
to you in your life where you've made
quite dramatic changes and I want to
just talk to you about them for example
you used to be a Buddhist According to
some of your friends but now you're
Christian you before Trump's
Inauguration in 2017 you posted an
anti-trump post now you're one of the
big trumpers you were very supportive of
John McCain after he died and called him
courageous and the hero and then you
turned on him you were a republican you
became an independent you then became a
Democrat you're now a republican again
so your critics would say come on Carol
who is the real Carrier Lake here you're
flip-flopping all over the place on all
this well
how do you please
you you're throwing a lot at me so let
me hit all of that I am a woman of
Christ and a woman of faith I grew up um
Lutheran and Catherine a Catholic
growing up I'm now an Evangelical and I
think that there's something you can
Garner from every religion in the world
and I and the Buddhists are peaceful and
I think it's absolutely wonderful uh you
know I've been very much into yoga in my
life and so I don't have a problem with
any religion of the world and wherever
you can find something that stirs your
soul and gives you peace in this
difficult time I think that's wonderful
I find that in the Bible and I am a
Christian and a Evangelical Christian
and I I don't judge anybody by their
religion I've never made an a negative
post about President Trump at all I
don't know what you're talking about and
I would it would challenge you well it
was a Facebook advice
let me clarify it was a Facebook post
we're showing it on screen it was one
that you posted to your Facebook which
was right on the eve of the inauguration
and after Fox News revealed this
apparently it then got taken down but it
was not my president and it was it was
pleased I've never been anything down
from my I've never taken anything down
from my Facebook post and I've never
printed anything uh derogatory toward
president Trump as a journalist it was
not my job to post anything derogatory
about the president I would often talk
about something happening in the news
and say hey what do you think this is
happening and this is happening what are
your thoughts that's how I use social
media as a journalist and I think that's
a really healthy way to use social media
where you get people kind of socializing
and discussing issues on social media
I've always been a supporter of
President Trump but I didn't feel the
need to put that out publicly as a
journalist you really should keep your
ideas in check I also covered the
mccains and I covered everybody fairly I
it's not my it's not my job as a
journalist to tell somebody how to think
about that
let me explain on John McCain because I
I knew John McCain read the post read
the post for me well I challenge you to
read the poster as well here's what I
would say about John McCain is that I I
knew him I interviewed him many times I
had huge admiration for him and it
seemed after he died you shared all that
admiration you called him courageous and
heroic and so on uh but then read the
post but then in your
campaigning about him and you you said
that Arizona produced a lot of losers so
people took that to mean John McCain
right
well I can't help if people think that I
mean that's kind of a silly thing to
think I covered John McCain I have
immense respect for his military career
you know he was a politician here for 40
years I covered him for many of that
many of those years and no politician is
free from criticism of their of their
work I mean I look at president Trump he
was criticized day in and out for you
know 24 hours a day seven days a week
and he's still being criticized even
though he's a private citizen we can
definitely criticize our politicians and
the work they do I know that that uh
that Senator McCain promised and I
covered him probably longer than you did
Pierce to uh end Obamacare replace it
with something better when he had the
opportunity and that fell squarely on
his shoulders he went in and gave the
thumbs down and didn't do what he
promised the people of Arizona
when he was running for uh Senate one of
the times that he was running for
re-election he did an ad saying build
the dang fence build the dang wall and
then when President Trump said you know
what let's do that the people do want
that he fought to The Nail against that
he was censured by the Republican party
here I know that on a world stage many
people know him but a lot of Republicans
in Arizona felt like he showed up for a
few months every six years to run for
re-election and then ignored a lot of
the issues facing Arizona
you should be free from criticism okay I
completely agree no one should be free
from criticism I think it was the
juxtaposition I know I haven't been I
haven't been and I'm going to come to
that but I think the only point I would
make is you were so
praiseworthy of him in his death and yet
very soon after that suddenly it looked
like you turned on him
well Pierce really honestly
someone has just passed away and he had
like he led he's an icon LED an amazing
life I said the Maverick has passed away
and that was that was his uh his
nickname as you know because you've
interviewed him
I have a heart and soul and I know the
suffering of losing a father I lost my
father more than a decade ago and I I
still
um tear up at the thought of of that and
I feel for the family I'm a human being
and so are they and I feel for that I've
not been unfairly critical of of John
McCain I think I've any criticism I've
launched at him was that he didn't do
what he told the people he would do and
I am not out to get anybody I actually
brought a lot of the Republican party
together I'm an America First Republican
we have McCain Republicans here and I
believe that we can work together we
agree a 95 of everything maybe 99 of
everything we Republicans do and we we
tend to kind of Duke things out and
debate and and I wish that okay what
about the other party did that okay
let me turn to one thing which is
splitting the party and that is this
issue of stolen elections so you've been
obviously Donald Trump support supported
you and you've been very supportive of
his belief that he had the 2020 election
stolen from it I've interviewed Donald
Trump and we had a great interview but I
took him on and said I don't think that
election was stolen from you and more
than that President Trump I think your
persistence in claiming it was is
damaging to your chances of potentially
winning again and I would say to you
Carrie Lee you're clearly a rising star
in the Republican firmament you've got a
lot of popularity in fact since you lost
the election and we'll come to whether
you think you have or not in a moment
but since you did a lot of money's come
in for you so people think Carrie late
Rising Star you know potentially on a
trump ticket who knows where that will
go and I'll ask you about that but you
again have not accepted the results of
the election and there is a belief that
it's almost deliberate it's like you've
looked at Donald Trump and thought you
know what there's a great way to make
money and fame for myself and that's to
be an election denier and I would simply
say to you I said to Donald Trump I
don't think it works for you guys I
don't think denying the result of
Democrats the election years is an
effective tool to actually win elections
that is the silliest thing I've ever
heard that is absolutely it's it's funny
actually I campaigned 525 days across
the most beautiful state in the country
Arizona and I know the people and I
worked incredibly hard and our
volunteers and the people gathered
around it really was a movement and you
weren't here to cover it unlike we've
ever seen in politics
of Arizona voter sir sir 72 percent of
Arizona voters believe that that
election something was wrong and it
wasn't honest 72 percent of arizonans
and I want to make sure I have children
I have two children 18 and 19 years old
I want to make sure when they grow up we
don't continue to run elections like a
Banana Republic we're on Election Day
voters showed up our voters showed up 75
to 25 3-1 on Election Day and the
machines weren't working they printed
intentionally the wrong image on the
ballot and that was meant to have the
ballot spit out and rejected by the
tabulators a quarter of a million times
on Election Day more than half of the
ballots were spit out
as you know
and we can continue to run on elections
there's been no independent
corroboration that there was anything
fraudulent about this election in fact
it's pretty clear that you lost to Katie
Hobbs your your rival 50.3 to 49.6 and
as with Donald Trump and I said to
where's the hard evidence he went down
all sorts of rabbit holes but he
couldn't produce there's a ton of peers
peers there's there's there's a mountain
of Hard Evidence and when we presented
it in our trial the other side didn't
even dispute the evidence they didn't
they had but not only had the election
results
yes well we can't continue to run
elections this way and we know that we
won and we're going to continue to fight
this in a court of law and it's really
rich that you're sitting across the pond
acting like you know what happened on
Election Day I did not see your smiling
face we had lots of international media
here covering election day in Arizona
yours is one face I didn't see in nor
did I see it you could have had my
smiling face arizonans
I would have loved to have seen you we
had more media covering our election
than I've ever seen cover any any story
here in Arizona and as I said I covered
Arizona for nearly 30 years so it's okay
that you are not comfortable with me
fighting this election and fighting for
election Integrity
let me clarify I don't I don't mind your
fighting spirit I Don't Mind Donald
Trump I've known him a long time well I
have every right to fight this election
absolutely right but it does come a
point
it does come a point when for the future
of democracy you and Donald Trump have
to accept at some point you lost an
election otherwise the entire system
collapses if your simple response to
losing is always we didn't lose we won
then democracy dies
Pierce I grew up in a family of nine I'm
the youngest my father was a history and
government teacher and a football coach
and he taught us that if we lose and we
lose fair and square we we congratulate
the winner we walk away
and that's exactly what I would do if
that was a fair and square election but
I'm fighting for the people of Arizona I
go all over this country I've been
probably to Six States since the
election in Arizona I can't walk 10 feet
without an arizonan saying I voted for
you everybody I know voted for you our
ballot was rejected on Election Day
please keep fighting for us I'm fighting
for the people of Arizona and I I don't
mean any offense to you but I frankly
don't give a damn what you think about
it I'm fighting for the people of
Arizona listen I truly am no offense
taken whatsoever let me ask you this
Pierce let me ask let me ask you a
question do you think it's right that
you show up on Election Day that's the
big day on Election Day and 60 of the
voting locations in the primarily
Republican locations have ballots that
are printed out wrong sorry machines
have four hour lines
is that okay all I know from my lofty uh
place here in London and I wasn't in
Arizona all I know is all the official
fact-checking entities that have looked
into all the claims do not conclude
come on
Pierce Pierce did you just fall off the
turnip truck we know about the fact
Checkers and we've seen them this has
all been revealed half of them are
leftists working for Facebook let's
let's be real okay
one final question
at what point would you accept that
you've lost
well we're do you think that we have a
right to move this through the court
system I think we do I know that we do
we have the rights
legal right today but my point is indeed
is there any point you've got a right to
do it is there any point where you would
accept that you lost
we are taking it to the Supreme Court
that's where we're taking it okay let me
ask you secondly a lot of rumor swelling
you might run to be Senator is that true
I have had many people reach out to me
and say you need to run for Senator we
have an opportunity here to win uh and
we're we're really concerned about what
would happen if we allow a socialist
like the Democrat who's jumped in or
someone like Kirsten Cinema who votes
with Joe Biden 95 93 of the time we need
to have someone like you run you're the
only Republican who can win uh it is in
the back of my mind but my number one
priority is my case and I want to see my
case through and if Donald Trump if
Donald Trump says to you he wants you to
be his running mate what would your
answer be
wow the hypotheticals this is crazy
if the royal family invites you in and
offers you a job what are you going to
do Pierce I mean these are hypotheticals
I'd say yes thanks thanks very much when
do I start where's my Palace
well I honest honest to goodness I have
not given that thought and and I think
the president's amazing who's a great
president greatest of my lifetime and I
know that every American was doing
better when he was in the white house
and I really miss the economy that he
helped lead I miss the fact that he
helped to end Wars rather than Star Wars
first president in my lifetime that
didn't start a war and I know that he
cares deeply about this country we we
really need to get back to putting the
people of this country first giving them
back their government and I am um I am
just focused on what I'm doing here in
Arizona a final question on Ukraine uh
president zielinski's here in London
gave a stirring speech to Parliament
um I'm curious why so many Republicans
seem to want Vladimir Putin to win
you know why don't you ask them
what's your view all I know is I am I am
here in Arizona and it is uh nothing is
more aggravating and
um anger inducing to the people of
Arizona then watching these buffoons
back in Washington DC take our
hard-earned money and write a check to
Ukraine over a hundred billion dollars
has gone to Ukraine and we sit here in
Arizona with a wide open border the
Narco terrorists and the drug cartels
with the help of the CCP in China are
pushing in and funneling record numbers
record amounts of fentanyl through
Arizona into the rest of this country
we're watching a Young Generation but
all those carry all those all those are
probably we have a wide open border and
they don't want to send but Carrie I
don't they don't want to send a penny
here I don't disagree with you about
those issues and they have to be tackle
but they have nothing to do with Ukraine
and again my curiosity is simply the
when Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait for
example America couldn't wait to get get
stuck in to kick him out and was and
most Republicans I know supported it and
yet here we have Vladimir Putin who is
on a whole different level of dictator
marching into a European country and to
my astonishment some Republicans seem to
think that the best answer to this is to
let him just take Ukraine and I'm just
bemused why why wouldn't every fiber of
a republican being be we have got to
defeat Putin wherever he he marches in
and tries to thwart democracy
well this Republican believes that we
need to make sure we're putting the
needs of Americans first and right now
Americans are struggling I've talked to
retirees who saved and did everything
right many of them were even veterans
they did everything right and they're
watching their retirement savings
evaporate under Joe Biden my focus is on
the people the good people of Arizona
and that's why I'm fighting for them
every day I continue to fight I watch
the people who are sitting in office
here and they are dead set on destroying
this state and making our lives making
us suffer and making us less safe so my
focus is on the people of Arizona and I
intend to keep my focus here we
oftentimes get involved in in skirmishes
and wars and try to start things up
overseas and I think the American people
are growing very weary of that
incredibly weary watching our
hard-earned money go overseas and we're
in a precarious spot if we continue to
behave that way and I don't think that's
the American Spirit okay well Carrie on
that we will disagree but it's been
great to interview you thank you for
coming on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
will follow your your Rising career with
great interest
and please come to Arizona I'd love to
tour you uh give you a tour of the
border and show you around and and maybe
we could even sit down and have lunch
and go over some of the evidence in our
case I would love to do that actually
I'll take you up on that Carrie Lake
thank you very much indeed
thank you pierce